the 2013 Venice Biennale promoting
global trends in art in the interview
2013 Biennale curator Massimiliano
Gianni
Massimiliano Joni Levine our it's called
the encyclopedic palace that is quite an
astonishing title it sounds more like a
museum than an art show is that a
deliberate choice to go back to the 19th
century actually the show has nothing to
do with the 19th century because
encyclopedias are certainly not invented
by our friends in the Enlightenment
the title comes from a model of an
imaginary museum conceived by an Italian
American artist Marino Ricci who dreamt
of a museum that would house all the
world's knowledge so it's an exhibition
about impossible dreams of total
knowledge and about artists and
eccentric figures that I have attempt to
encapsulate all the knowledge in the
world in a place or in a system or in a
series of images how does that translate
into an art show what are we to expect
well it does look more like a museum
than a traditional biml and it means
that the show expands across more than
100 years of history
he starts its epicenter is Carl Gustav
Jung red book which is an incredible
manuscript on which the famous
psychologist worked for more than 16
years and they showed zigzags across
time and tries to tell the story of many
obsessions and many flights of the
imaginations and particularly tries to
understand with the place for the images
we have inside ourselves our dreams and
our visions in a word that it's more and
more submerged by artificial images you
have once said that art is a place where
the visitor should make an experience a
personal experience so what experience
are in store for the visitor in Venice
this year well I think the show is about
vision both the vision
we see with our eyes closed and both the
act of seeing there are more than 4000
individual objects in the International
Show so I think it's going to be an
adventure for the eyes and a prolonged
act of looking and I think I hope it
will be an experience of pleasure for
the eyes but one also for the intellect
because it is a show about knowledge and
about how beautiful the dream of knowing
everything can be and unfortunately
though it's a dream that is often bound
to fail you have selected more than 150
artists the work of more than 150
artists what were the criteria was it
the top of the best-selling painters
list or was it the young and trendy the
hot talent actually the reason why also
the list is so big is that I wanted to
take away this expectation that this is
a top 10 or a top hundred he included
also professional artists and many other
strange figures writers thinkers
outsider artists I didn't want to make a
list of suggestions for collectors I
think it's more about individuals who
have devoted their life to a project and
some of them are professional artists
others worked in complete obscurity for
a great part of their life so I think
ultimately is sure about telling the
stories behind the artworks and I hope
that's what remains to the visitors say
an exhibition which objects tell stories
the art world in the last 10 years and
every year more so has turned into quite
a craze a hype of names and money do you
find it difficult to even evade that
white noise of the art market I think I
mean the encyclopedic palace and in
general the Biennal with its 88 national
pavilions offers a picture of the
artwork that it's much bigger than the
height they usually media talk about you
know we we often think that art is just
big money because newspapers talk about
it but art is a much bigger world it's a
world in which more than 88 nations are
happy to show what they are doing and I
tried in my show particularly with the
inclusion of more eccentric figures to
move away from the cannon and from the
idea of the price tag and that's why I
also included many works which belong to
museums we have works on loans from
natural historical museums and from very
unusual places to sort of break away
from the equivalents quality equals
money experts and especially we
journalists expect from from a biannual
that it kind of reflects the
contemporary art world and also the
tight geist the in a way the state of
the world is that something a Biennale
can really offer well I wanted to call
the benighted encyclopedia palace
because the expectation of bionis to
capture all the world's knowledge is
certainly doomed to fail as much as the
or it is dream I do think the thing
today being contemporary also means
having a access to the past and to the
present that is completely different
this show by looking at the desire to
know and see everything talks about a
present that is obsessed with
information that is obsessed with
knowledge I'd like to say anyway it's a
prehistory of an age of information or a
prehistory or Wikipedia and it tries to
look at how in the last century we have
lived with an obsession of knowledge and
information so I hope you will talk
about the present but from a perspective
that connects to the past the idea of
national pavilions because we don't have
that art show the answer encyclopedic
palace but we also have almost 90
national pavilions and the number is
growing by the year the idea was always
contested but that doesn't seem very
relevant now that obviously the
participation in Venice seems to be more
and more attractive why is it so well I
often make a joke that the National
pavilion are a bit like the atomic bomb
as long as the superpowers had it he was
fine and then when others people wanted
the superpowers say oh that's obsolete I
think it's the fact that you have 88
nations that come to Venice and they
want to express their existence on the
world stage means that the model is far
from being obsolete it means also that
the Biennal has been able to transform
itself if you
the Giardini you have a picture of the
world that it's very much based on an
old-fashioned Western centric sense of
the world and now in the arson alley we
have Chinese pavilion we have
Argentinean pavilion we have a war that
is in the United Emirates we in the
Arsenal I think it's a new geopolitical
landscape that has been presented and
the other day I just looked at the map
of the world in the office where we put
little flags on all the countries that
are represented and 88 countries is
still less than half of the countries in
the world so I think it's important that
we keep present in art from everywhere
in the world and to use this as an
occasion to present a word that it's
international but not flattened and I
think that's what Venice is very special
for because it's a global picture with
lots of contrast and not a flat world
the new centers of the art world like
Latin America even Africa the Arab world
are they properly represented when I
listen to you it sounds like there
arrived in Venice they're here and there
is no more discussion about it yeah I
think Venice is a very special place
it's a place where the West is dreamt of
the East back from the days of Marco
Polo and certainly it is a place where
many countries who have come to the
attention of the West recently a founder
place and I think this year we have in
the same building in India sonali we
have Argentina United Emirates Turkey
and also the Vatican the Holy See and
they have all opened permanent pavilions
and I think that's an exciting view of
what the world can be today you have
written that you want to show you want
to explore and at the Biennale
especially in your show the power of the
imagination now in a world that is
flooded by images day by day in a world
of information what is the contribution
of the artist
I mean he has to compete with all the
images we see every day I wanted in fact
the exhibition is very dense the in the
central pavilion and in their Sonali
they are more than 4,000
individual objects I wanted to make a
show that anyway can compete on the same
level as the media by flooding the the
eyes of the viewer but at the same time
I hope that each and every image in the
show as an intensity and a purity that
escapes that the volatility of
commercial images hands melting with an
art historian there was a great
inspiration for this show said that the
first medium of images are not the TV
the camera or the screen but is actually
our body and our brain when we close our
eyes with dreams and we see images and I
hope the exhibition can help the viewer
focus on the internal images and the
space of imagination and what we see
when we move away from technology or
when we discover that we are self media
and we ourself carry images within our
heads have you integrated the digital
the virtual world in your show the show
in a way looks at the prehistory of our
society and particularly in the arsenal
the Arsenal is structure following the
progression of 16th century wonder
camera and in cabinets of curiosity
which were usually organized as a
progression from the natural to the
artificial so the show starts with the
artist looking at nature trying to
decrypt the code of nature any answer
with the series of works mostly by
younger artists that represent our
digital condition and this idea of a
universal visibility and and so yes I
think the the end of the show is very
much about this illusion we have that we
can see everything and that everything
is in our pocket through the help of
digital technology so it seems like
we're getting a long stretch from the
past to the future and everything
included in that palace I don't know if
that's a mirage you work in New York as
a museum director you've co-managed
they're very successful Berlin be
another some years ago now you're in
Venice what's the most inspiring place
for you you're a you know like a nomad
of the art world so
I don't think of myself much of a nomad
I say as a joke that it's important to
spend as much time on books than on
planes and and this show anyway is also
tribute to the book starts with Young's
red book and he talks about books as
places for the imagination and places
where you can hide and where you can
escape at the same time I work very well
both in New York because it's a very
exciting place and I feel all surrounded
to serve the foundation in Milan where
we do know magic projects I think
ultimately and this is what this
exhibition is also about I work very
well in my head it's yeah I tried also
for this show not to travel everywhere
in the world
the but also to travel across history
and and to remind ourself that new
discoveries can be made when you explore
less canonical works thank you for the
interview and good luck for the show
thank you